je rappellerai deux choses d'abord c'est
au départ
le premier ministre néerlandais le
recruteur qui a été particulièrement
virulent pour défendre la position des
institutions européennes vis-à-vis de
ces gouvernements hongrois polonais
première chose c'est pas la france par
exemple n'a pas été tout à fait au
départ de cette démarche et là je
rappellerai aussi que pendant la
campagne électorale des dernières
élections européennes
cette l'importance de la règles de
conditionnalité pour l'octroi des
financements de l'union européenne était
vraiment un sujet majeur
donc c'est vrai que parlement européen
veut absolument que l'on tienne compte
de ces de cette question des règles de
conditionnalité
donc cela il faut pas l'oublier alors
ensuite que viktor orban on se plein je
pense à juste titre que l'on en fait une
véritable affaire politique
alors qu'il ne faut pas confondre bien
évidemment les questions purement morale
qui serait là là l'interdiction de
l'avortement etc ou des questions très
familial avec ce qui concerne
véritablement l'état de droit c'est à
dire la liberté de la presse et pertes
et de l'opinion d'opinion la liberté la
justice indépendante et c'est donc il ne
faut pas mélanger les choses et je
crains que malheureusement cela se fasse
y compris au sein du parlement européen
donc il faut quand même garder essayer
de garder un regard le plus le plus
équilibré possible ne pas incriminer
systématiquement le gouvernement
de victor ban et le gouvernement
polonais mais néanmoins être ferme sur
le fait qu'il n'y a des règles qui
doivent être respectées
quand on adhère à l'union européenne et
que ces règles là ont été acceptées lors
de l'adhésion de ces pays
donc l'état de droit doit être respecté
effectivement
[Musique]